مكياج الينا الان
عبد القادر اهلا بك ما اخر اخبار التطورات
المعارك على خط المواجهه شرقا
مرحبا
الروسيه تكثف عمليتها العسكريه في الشرقي
وجنوبي اوكرانيا تحسبا وتمهيدا لما يشاع
هنا في اوكرانيا عن عوده العمليات
الميدانيه مطلعه الربيع القادم من الجهه
الشماليه يتخوف تتخوف الاداره العسكريه
الاوكرانيا ان تعود العمليات من الحدود
المتخمه لمدينه خارطه
اما جنبا من من شبه جزيره القرم ومن البحر
الاسود بعد ان اعلنت في الايام القليله
الماضيه مجموعه فاجنر سيطرتها على مدينه
سوليدار الاستراتيجيها مره ثانيه
همم مجموعه من القرى المتممه لمدينه ضخمه
الاستراتيجيه التي تعد حلقه وصل بين الجهه
الشرقيه والجنوب الغربي تريد تريد مجموعه
اختراق هذه مدينه من اجل الوصول الى مدينه
كرامته
تسهيل عمليه دخول الجيش النظامي الروسي
واصال الامدادات القادمه من الجهه
الجنوبيه في الجهه المقابله اك الاداره
العسكريه الاوكرانيه انها استطاعت ان
تتصدى لمجموعه فاجنر
بقصفها
للمنشاءات ولخطوط السكك الحديديه هناك من
اجل قطع الامدادات القادمه من البحر
الاسود ومن شبه جزيره القرم الى المنطقه
الشرقيه هذا ميدانيه في المنطقه الشرقيه
اذا ذهبنا الى المنطقه الجنوبيه استهدفت
القوات الروسيه مره ثانيه مدينه زفوريجيا
وخريصون
الصواريخ بعيده المدى القادمه من الغواصات
الموجوده والباخرات الموجوده في البحر
الاسود تريد تريد همم
موسكو وتريد القياده العسكريه الروسيه من
هذه العمليه العسكريه او واسعه النطاق
استرجاع اكبر قدر ممكن من المدن قبل همم
اقل من شهر على مرور السنه من بدايه الغزو
الروسي اوكرانيا